over 100 years ago this guy changed the
way we look at the universe with his
general theory of relativity but with
the new understanding came mysteries
about the invisible substances
underpinning the cosmos we call them
dark matter and dark energy the lack of
a better term and they make up about 95
of our universe the new Euclid telescope
will use its near-infrared spectrometer
and photometer to look back in time
towards the formation of galaxies and
the expansion of the universe revealing
the role that dark matter and energy
play in these phenomena in the process
Euclid will create the most detailed 3D
map of the universe ever covering an
area of over one-third of the night sky
Euclid also carries with it a visible
light camera which can capture images of
the universe as we'd experience it
through our own eyes just as Hubble did
in about three weeks Euclid should
arrive at its final resting place which
is in the same neighborhood as the James
Webb Space Telescope so we're wishing
you good luck in its mission to reveal
the secrets of the Dark Universe